and i'm not going to mention their name
to to embarrass anybody there's a roller
and a bare-handed attempt by moose takas
and that'll be an infield hit for
jonathan scope getting ahead number one
and putting those hitters in the hole
all three hitters so far he's worked
ahead in the count
sonny gray did a good job of that last
night
this one's a shot and it's a fair ball
into the left field corner
there we go here comes jonathan's scope
and the tigers are on the board
cj crone does it again enjoy standing in
and he has home run
number two on the season already for
joey bottom and just like that a 1-1
game
[Music]
after admittedly back-to-back subpar
years
vado at least for one game and one
at-bat looks like the bottle we saw for
the prior decade
that'll brighten up breads fans evenings
for sure you know there's a saying that
a lot of batting coaches tell the hitter
when he comes out of the on deck circle
be ready to hit
there's a bullet right by goodwill
and that'll be scored a base hit by
mustaches
2-2 to maven swing and a miss and
castillo carves him up three strikeout
for luis castillo
reliving the story through nova's eyes
about
there's a drive into right field by
freddy galveston that one is gone
galvez a season ago a career-high 23
home runs
and has number one
here in 2020
and the reds take the lead for the first
time in this one a three to one ball
game the o2
see ya slider off the outside edge and
back to the duck out is cabrera 2-2 on
austin romaine
and that's all for the tigers in roma
this figures to be castillo's final
inning of work pitching into the sixth
and he's picked up his ninth strike out
of the game two more to go
and caught on strikes candelario
double digits for luis castillo coming
up for castillo two balls two strikes
two outs and that's all she wrote
[Applause]
my oh my luis castillo
the 1-0
swinging a high fly ball head in the air
to left field fairly deep this ball is
going to carry and this ball is gone a
home run wow off the bat it looked like
a routine fly to left and it just kept
carrying austin romine with a home run
and the tigers are within one here in
the seventh inning now trailing three to
two now cabrera waiting on a 3-2 on the
way
swinging a fly ball deep down the
left-field line will it stay fair it is
gone a home run
miguel cabrera ripped it down the left
field line just inside the foul pole two
runs shot
and the tigers take a 4-3 lead here in
the seven sally a fly ball that'll
continue to carry into right center
field and that game is tied wow
no sooner had we seen a ball just like
that when two batters ago
when it left the back chris much like
zen zelles but after watching senzels
you thought maybe it had a chance and
now we're tied at four
does he come back and throw another
change up here does he try to get him up
in the zone with the fastball let's see
roll mine's setting up and in
fastback it works
here's the 2-2
lifted to center and deep
jones is back and he's got it
two up two down here's the 2-2
launch to left-center
jacoby jones wears a crown off the
cincinnati closer
a two-run blast and the tigers surge
back in front pitch here 2-1
ground ball
spare chrome's got it
joey bottle's got to quit hitting the
ball to cj crowe
great job right there the ball was hit
hard again
in game number two
joe jimenez
against suarez
here in the ninth where the tigers up
two
and a man on second
[Applause]
fly ball left field
jimenez gets the job done and the tigers
have their first win of the year
they knock off the reds 6-4 big home
runs from romine cabrera and that man
jacoby jones